A solo días determinar los festejos
mundialistas la política devolvió la
atención y la polarización Argentina la
Corte Suprema de Justicia ordenó al
gobierno nacional que entregue unos 997
millones de dólares adicionales a la
ciudad de Buenos Aires que provienen de
los impuestos recaudados por el fisco se
trata de los llamados copro
participables que se entregan entre las
provincias y la capital según una tabla
de porcentajes establecida por la ley en
2016 el entonces presidente Mauricio
macri aumento por decreto la suma que
recibía la ciudad de Buenos Aires del
1,40% al
3,75%. esto justo cuando el gobierno
local quedaba en manos de Horacio
Rodríguez larreta su delfín político
posteriormente en 2020 el actual jefe de
estado Alberto Fernández recortó Los
fondos a la capital del 3,75 al 2,32% y
ahora la corte dictaminó que pasen al
2,95% Fernández aseguró que no acatará
la resolución en un día aciago para el
federalismo por este
tremendo que ha sacado la corte que
genera una enorme desigualdad
entre la ciudad más suculenta del país y
el resto del país la decisión de
Fernández generó un fuerte revuelo entre
la oposición la coalición cívica ya
presentó una demanda penal por
alzamiento desobediencia judicial abuso
de autoridad y violación de los deberes
de funcionario público el presidente
pidió presentó una recusación contra los
jueces de la corte para que no
participen en este proceso
Esto no es contra la ciudad esto es
contra la Constitución nacional
expertos aseguran que la decisión De no
respetar el fallo sí incumple la
Constitución y sectores de la oposición
ya consideran pedir un juicio político
contra Fernández